choosing to end ones
which is a huge topic and on the one
hand problem
naturalist SAR much more willing to let
people choose to end their own life and
a lot of religious people are on the
other hand if what we have to offer by
the way of meaningfulness is mattering
to other people then how much should it
matter what the other people think
versus the individuals right to end
their own life does anyone have strong
feelings you know I have strong feelings
yes we discussed it in the car so I'll
hold off I do the paper a few years ago
mr. this paper called old body apoptosis
[Music]
the idea was you ask people would you
prefer to die a lingering death in a
hospital or be struck by lightning
everybody says how do I rather be struck
by lightning
so then the questions could that be
arranged this was for a journal that was
it was called Homo sapiens 2.0 the idea
was to describe some improvement to Homo
sapiens that a you would endorse and be
you and undergo yourself yeah if it was
made technologically feasible in the
near future
and my choice was whole-body apoptosis
yeah this is the idea of arranging for
people to die by lightening strikes by
which I mean you have a device various
technological ways just give you one
there's a device is implanted than you
you know at birth if you're a little
kiddo or now which it's you can't get
into it to see what date is on and what
it does is it's set to go off at some
unpredictable time between your let's
say 85th and 90th birthday and as soon
as you enter that period you're sort of
the lame-duck you don't know you can die
at any time
oh and and one little improvement was
you get a 10-minute warning this is how
you can get off the highway pull up your
pants
call your kids whatever you know
mistress so but but the point that was
the main point of this which no matter
how hard I stressed it a lot of people
didn't get is a lot of people want it to
then they wanted to be able to control
it and I said don't last the whole point
the thing is the unexamined life isn't
worth living but as Kurt buyer once
memorably said the over examined life is
nothing to write home about either and
you don't want the state your heirs your
friends or yourself making quality of
life judgments about you you want it to
come out of the blue with a 10-minute
warning that's the ideal way to go now
we could technologically we could do it
politically could we do it that's a hard
one because because I wouldn't impose
this on anybody we do it yourself why do
you like that better than simply
allowing yourself to make them for
yourself that's only a part of it I the
reason that I would do this is I don't
want my family and friends and society
sort of looking at their watches and
looking at me and thinking don't you
think it's about time I don't want the
quality of my life to be the thing I
have to think about all the time I don't
want to think about the quality of my
life now
what the quality of my life is gonna be
next year I want to just go ahead and
live until I die yeah you don't have an
exponential decay you can't have between
18th and 19th birthday you know you've
got a 90th birthday it's actually easier
to arrange anyway sure can we just take
a vote how many people would have Dan's
device implanted in them half day that's
a device that will kill you at a random
moment so it's about half
I know bears or any of those people
they're right to have that device if
they would give me the right to to
exercise free will and then my life
whenever I wanted but if you haven't
done it by age 85 this process takes
over and takes out of your hands and out
of your your heirs hands and out of the
state's hands the main thing is if you
haven't already made a quality-of-life
judgment and popped yourself off this
will be done without a quality-of-life
judgment and that saves you from having
to either think about it or stop
everybody else from thinking about
hundred and one and you know 96 she
called me up just like I quit smoking
well well you know one of them voted for
Obama one of one of the one of the
implications of the view and I bring it
out very clearly is you have to set the
timing on this early enough so that if
all goes well you die in your prime that
yes you the price the price you pay the
price you pay for not lingering and
getting worse when we're somewhere
somewhere so worse is that you you're
willing to risk lopping
some good years off your life so in it
you're right that's part of your success
quality of life now you're saying that
somebody's getting old can't come to
that same resolution that maybe they can
come to terms with ability and is ready
to go but you only you know she's very
competent that's a that's a real
advantage
she you're only age addres 'let --iv yes
you know lives alone and until I'd say a
month ago unassisted so it's only since
the month or so that she's been assisted
that there's been a sense of like I'm
really totally done but any you know if
if the mind goes I guess you can worry
about the judgment but if the mind
doesn't go I mean it doesn't always have
to okay absolutely true a lot of people
that are that our centenarians with full
active lives there are many many more
people whose last year's are dismal
dreary they are a terrible burden to
themselves and their families that are
suffering and and there's nothing we can
do about it to be clear you are making
this a voluntary surrender of the device
so you know how to just to be clear
although it sounds like you'd like to
see a lot of people do it let me decide
I frankly not really what I like the
right to give myself the stuff that you
can't buy over the counter by the way
that you should be able to I would give
a majority vote in this room the right
to kill me if I become a burden to
society yeah I do that maybe not this
group
national group that believes morality
you